prongs that's an optimal octopus
these are sardines almost it's a
mackeral mackeral octopus No thank you
that's the internationally acclaimed
chef Rene Redzepi with a preview of
what's heading to the new menu at Noma
the one-time world's best restaurant
reopens in Copenhagen next month but
CBS's Sunday mornings Mo Rocca didn't
have to go to Denmark for the recipes
from Redzepi the chef's wife Nadine is
now being heralded for her cooking at
home let's see this one here if you're
going to forage in someone's garden you
can taste this this is called ground
elder make it the garden of a
world-class chef there might be a bit of
soil in it but that's okay Rene Redzepi
put Nordic food on the map a few years
after opening the Copenhagen restaurant
Noma in 2003 menu made headlines in the
food world with ingredients like live
ants locally sourced of course and Noma
topped the list of world's best
restaurants four times but at the home
he shares with his wife Nadine and their
three daughters the chef is rarely in
the kitchen
and you cooked together at home I mean
we could but I I like the couple met at
Noma before Rene or his restaurant
became famous we actually met on the
elevator going up to the changing room
that was an awkward silence and then
Nadine she said so how long have you
worked here
[Laughter]
and I thought that was perfect in your
role with the restaurant at first was
waiting tables but I liked being there
so much so for some reason I took lots
and lots of shifts so I ended up like
being marrying someone on their first
date Nadine offered to cook you know by
some cosmic force Nadine and cooked the
the very thing that I enjoyed more than
when I was growing up which was chicken
there was and it was our first date you
know did you have any idea how much that
would resonate with him no you would
know okay it was it was meant to be it
was right that's it that was that was it
is you want to get a chopping board
she's run this kitchen ever since
don't break the egg yolk during our
visit she showed us how to make wild
mushroom porridge with eggs one of the
recipes from her first cookbook downtime
deliciousness at home if there are any
leaves or bugs on them just brush them
off no bugs are not on the menu here mmm
three mystic stars in this note the
cookbook also includes her husband's
family dinner favorite roast chicken and
he's a tender yeah it's so tender but I
think you know Dean she stuffs it
because if it's not stuffed usually all
the heat goes in and it cooks the breast
also from from him from within and
that's when you get many of Nadine's
dishes are inspired by the family's
travels her mother's chicken with Indian
bread middle-eastern beef with lentils
and Japanese gyoza I think it's kind of
acting as a sponge every time you meet
something every time you go somewhere
variety is essential with three smaller
and demanding mouths to feed you want to
make them happy but you also want them
not to reject it which is the big big
one
well your kids actually eat it well
right they're the toughest critics of
all right yeah and the ones that matter
most well you know it's amazing but
they're also can we say pain-in-the-ass
one week they want white foods only like
pastas and bread you know next week they
they they love raw things at me right so
need a yeah raw broccoli and
yeah so this is an array of things that
we have to experiment with where we open
with no much set to reopen in a new
location this is a wild danish lobster
the restaurants Test Kitchen moved into
a building in the family's backyard a
proximity that's proven beneficial for
both Renee and Nadine Redzepi what would
your cooking be like if you'd never met
Nadine if I want Amanda Deane I don't
think it would have at all been what it
is no way look at these
yeah the potatoes Oh for CBS this
morning I'm Mo Rocca at the Redzepi
residence in Copenhagen oh don't you
love the two of them together so cute a
great love story and so much in common
yeah and I love that even top chefs have
picky kids right right it's hard to
convince your kids to eat the food yes
makes you feel better period thinks her
kids are a pain in the butt anybody wait
rickets doesn't I know good food comes
from love yeah